[Music]
and daddy with a gun news dad with the
gun submitted by who dat boy who dat who
dat an off-duty officer guns down
robbers while holding his baby that's
time that's like action barge that's
what it sounds like freeze [ __ ]
it's so loud for the baby ears yeah it's
not for adult years maybe he was
covering the baby's ears to his chest it
was an armed robber yeah oh so you guys
life or death to Robert oh oh I heard
about this so you know I took a class
this weekend this past weekend and so
the Special Forces guy if he was telling
me that this guy actually played it
right cuz a lot of people may think that
oh there's a bad guy right you're in a
hallway and you think you have a gun and
once you hit someone you want to go
through this hallway or if you're like
in an aisle of a supermarket whatever
you start getting momentum you get
confidence you know okay I want to
attack the split as hard as possible but
that's actually not the best thing to do
because you don't know you eliminate a
threat here but you reach the end of the
hallway and there could be two of the
homies with guns so you actually want to
take your time and you want your bullets
to do the work for you and what he was
explaining to me about this story was
this guy he came was able to eliminate
one threat and because he knew what he
was doing instead of rushing for to see
if there any other threats he actually
backed up is he's trying to save a life
yeah cuz he ain't trying to [ __ ] play
call of duty right now
yeah and try to get the most hit kill
[ __ ] score yeah so you actually did
the right thing well your goal isn't to
be a hero is to eliminate threats that's
why I always get shot when I play
airsoft I'm always storming into
buildings and in getting riddled with
bullets
I will never survive in the real world
but now I know that information I'm
gonna hide in the closet with a shotgun
after this guy is an off-duty sergeant
oh yeah and so takes place in Brazil he
was at a pharmacy got a nice ass too
it says more and more like Bart blaster
you see his [ __ ] ass she's my little
rat a little bunny with a nice ass
that's right picture Oh what is my
bucket like twerking [ __ ] right yeah
BAM that was this guy yeah yeah so the
name is Rafael and so he was at a
pharmacy shopping with his wife and his
little boy so the wife was talking to
the clerk when the two armed robbers
approached the clerk and that's when the
sergeant off duty sergeant he saw the
threat and then immediately he's just
started shooting and I'll just show you
the rest of the video oh there's a video
yeah just so you guys know both of the
robbers died he killed them kill them if
there were trying to hurt people whoa
did he just shoot him in the back no
that was someone else and it's kind of
dangerous though with all with all those
people walking around the baby she's
kind of secured that area yeah and then
he goes take care of the second guy he
was saying that the reason why he's shot
was because he felt that the robber was
gonna immediately shoot at him yeah yeah
exactly
he killed them he killed them man so
it's nothing like the movies once you
get hit by a bull you pretty much gone
the Pens yeah I say that both good died
at the scene
by the time the ambulance there's no
dude in the movies like they always
shoot the hero in the most convenient
places like it's like you get grazed or
like a little bit where you can recover
yeah I think I think that's the best
places to get shot I want to get shot
there if I'm in a gunfight your arm yes
I could say I got shot like yeah but I
survived you know and then like but you
have the story to tell but like in
reality that bullets probably gonna hit
my liver or something and poison my body
and you know something else is gonna or
if it doesn't you just gonna like
shooting this stupidest place like your
earlobe
want to talk about yeah you get your
ears pierced yeah underneath your chin
yeah big shot before but all right time
to tell the story yeah yeah I want time
I don't how to tell you nothing you get
through his hair you get shot up on one
side of the cheek and it leaves the
other side of the cheek you want to see
why I got shot
you know everyone like to talk about
their like battle scars yeah I got
[ __ ] stabbed here this pits like look
at my shot and it's like a bear PJs like
the button is a really gross looking
battle scar [ __ ] cauliflower ears
yeah those things aren't dis it's super
disgust they are the most nastiest
[ __ ] things I've ever seen in my life
I've never seen girls with it wrestling
I know but girls that rust they're
probably smart enough to drain it that's
why guys are just like you literally pop
it and they trade it out yeah like judo
girls they have it no how come they
don't have it yeah and there's dudes
that don't so I always wore headgear but
there's a lot of guys they're just like
I'm not gonna wear headgear but I don't
want to have [ __ ] whack ass here like
you so I didn't they're just people that
they wear the right protection it looks
like a cup for the ears like if you look
at like [ __ ] what's his name like
Dominick Cruz has huge ears and he's
like some cauliflower on his [ __ ]
there's that one fight word dude just
got it was like an overhand right and
hit it in the side of the ear explosion
you know what's a cool battle scar
though [ __ ] up bists have you yeah
have you seen like karate masters that
are like 80 years old and you [ __ ]
look at their fists and it looks like a
turtle's Oh like a turtle skin yeah like
a but it's like it's like it's like nubs
and it looks like weapons like and it
looks like a gargoyles finger you know
what's so weird about those hands -
there's fingers get really thick they're
just it's just like five of these like
on that and it could pierce through
boards like with different gang signs
and kind of a shocker like kangaroo what
kind of go back with your cauliflower
thing like yes it looks nasty but at the
same time it tells people don't [ __ ]
with me cuz it like
or distilled you're really irresponsible
when I've seen it I'm like oh [ __ ] that
personnel that whole fights for sure so
you can get rid of it by draining yeah
but before out with not it'll scar
tissue forms and then you have to get
surgery so once you drain it it becomes
goes back to its normal self you have to
drink immediately Oh cuz cuz I had a
co-worker that how cauliflower cuz he
was training to become like a Brazilian
jiu-jitsu champion but then like I don't
know whatever happened to that but he
had like a big Holly flower ear and I
was like it was all bony one it was all
in one side and I was like like can you
get that fixed he's like no like I would
probably like have to do something but
it's permanent yeah yeah if they never
got it fixed what it was having happened
so that's partition will form then you
have to get surgery for it so it's just
like this gross thing that I've seen
nasty it looks like a balloon on the
side of your head but if you I was like
watching some interviews about like
something like you know BJJ dudes that
did it in Brazil it was like their rite
of passage like they wanted it because
it was so cool because that's I'm saying
I think it looks cool I think it's
disgusting it's gross but then it
communicates to the world Europe it
looks like a crumpled up piece of
newspaper I didn't but it communicate to
the world I'm not a [ __ ] know it
communicate the world that you are very
responsible and you did not go to the
hospital I don't think anyone looks at
an ear goes out there they're
responsible they go like oh [ __ ] if some
[ __ ] goes down I'm gonna go on that
guy's good side cuz he's amputation know
if the [ __ ] goes down I'm going somebody
with a gun yeah I'm wait for that one
gotta tackle somebody wait for a gun guy
so I know what happens during wrestling
but then what exactly goes down is it
like them that's like the rubbing of
your ear against a hard surface the
floor what nope she's so fascinated how
it that's how you create that's how you
get the fluid so like you know in
wrestling like so this is this like whoa
favorite camera finds it it's all like
what the [ __ ] am i doing no you're fine
he's learned to be gentle that's because
of Tiger okay I'm holding you so like it
and resting like you tie up a lot right
together here and let's say you grab me
so if I'm if I have my forehead against
her ear and we're like smashing hard or
if I have her face against the mat and
I'm like smashing her ear to the mat
that's how you click it it's like this
is happening to your ear all this fluid
and there's tears and so when they drain
it is actually blood so they'll see
blood come out of it yeah it's pretty
[ __ ] disgusting that's crazy that's
like I so crazy if we lived in like
let's say Texas or wherever they let you
carry your gun just wherever you go
would you do you think you'd do some
[ __ ] like this where you see like an
immediate threat you have your gun on
you yet if they had guns I don't know
maybe I mean if it's if it's like a big
ass like riding I probably the first
thing I do is get typed at her and
probably go to the back of the store
first yeah yeah it's a public place too
because you know it makes it even more
dangerous when there's random people
around if it's in your own home and you
know where everyone is that's a lot
different because there's only targets
and it's different to when it's your
home because you know they're
specifically coming for your [ __ ] right
because in this case they they could
have Rambo I don't know their situation
but if he felt like his life was
threatened it makes sense he has no
other choice I also forgot to mention
that when the robbers approached the
clerk and his wife he shouted out that
he he identified himself as an officer
and so that's when [ __ ] went down but
yeah like he felt that that need to
protect the situation since he is enough
dude that's also different cuz he has a
social responsibility because as a
civilian I don't want to murder anybody
for fun even though I'm curious but as a
police officer no but it's it's
different though so like because I have
a curious because I have a gun there's
robbers there's a part of me the
imagination part that goes here's my
time yeah okay see if you can kill
someone or wound him no no here's my
time to be a hero
Oh superstar I could kill them and
everyone's gonna give me a trophy no but
you said you're curious what are you
curious about how it feels to murder
someone
but legally and be called the hero for
it right but there's the other part of
me is like if I do this there's no
turning back and do I really want to you
know murder these two guys because even
though they pose a threat am I really
really threatened I could run away with
my family we can hide we can hide in the
back in the bathroom until the coast is
clear you know like yeah do I really
need to kill them I don't I'm just
really scared like in these type of
situations where there's like a camera
they're gonna catch me leaving my
children
we hear that a bit like this is gonna
count like oh [ __ ] Wow Muriel in the way
I tossed Muriel off the way I'm just
gonna point it is on camera [ __ ] they
have like in Halloween where they're
going trick-or-treating with their kid
and there's me get like a junk and they
leave their kid and there's just like
proof for the rest of my life that I
left my children
[Music]
[Applause]